how's it going guys welcome to a new
video today we're going to be unboxing
a diagonal monitor
so super cool it's a vh240a from hp
and it's basically just a uh a 1080p
vertical monitor so for a long time i
have wanted a vertical monitor let me
just show you
what my setup looks like it's i know
it's not super impressive
cheap table yada yada so over here i've
got two monitors that i'm you know i'm
pretty happy with
but over here my third one is a
little bargain bin monitor which is
actually half decent but uh
you know for a long time i've wanted a
vertical monitor in this spot
so finally broke down and bought one out
of pocket
no funding no sponsor anything like that
this is purely coming out of my own
pocket
all right so let's get to it
all right so i'm just pulled with my
fingers
use my manly fingernails
and i'm really excited about this i've
never had a vertical monitor before
except at workplaces
never had one at home so i feel like
it's going to really ramp up my home
office and
maybe my phone's productivity hopefully
that's my productivity
all right
there we go let's put it on the side
here
[Music]
give you guys the view
plastic like holding it all together
there's something in there probably base
plate
cables more cables all right so let's
get it out of here
and to do that i'm just going to flip
the box over
power adapter cable audio
support cable warranty hdmi cable
uh yeah uh i think i
think my video album my computer only
has one
hdmi out so that's kind of a problem
actually
all right this doesn't come out here i
don't know if it's getting caught on the
side here or what i guess we have to
actually pull harder
i'm glad whatever this little plastic
thing is i'm kind of glad to have it
so there we go i finally got it out
there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
of some sort
and now we'll start revealing the goods
here is the mount
it looks like it's probably just going
to go in the base plate there
goes up and down it looks like
it's got rails there to go up and down
and i'm guessing the spins
so this is a pretty standard base amount
and i guess
you know in theory if you already have a
monitor with a base amount you can just
buy
or yeah if you have a monitor that takes
this mount
you can probably just buy one of these
it says
trying to use it to spin it looks like
it spins but it's got a circle
there oh i'll mess with it later i'm
sure i'm really bad guys
all right so here's the main monitor
getting out of here
without breaking it and then we'll set
it up
all right there she is
little quick setup guide i think most of
this is pretty self-explanatory
okay so they just hook up all the cables
there she is wow beautiful all right i'm
going to leave it on for a second so i
don't smudge it while i'm setting it up
all right now let's go over to the setup
over here
all right so this is about to get
changed
so i'm going to remove this
all monitor i've also got my little usb
thing here
that plug now this one was hooked up
with hdmi so it's gonna it's gonna need
some
some edits i'm gonna need to change this
cable setup
and i've gotta think about that son
because
let's see my current video card let me
see if i can get down there and show you
this it only has
oh god you can't see that at all but it
basically has
two hdmi or one hdmi
two dvi and
or yeah two display ports
and a dvi so i'm using one of the
display ports i'm using the only
hdmi already
and i'm using the display port already
so we'll see
the old monitor looks like it has a base
amount as well
so i could have just let's see
i could just literally attach that base
amount to this and rotate this one
vertical but
see that's the cool thing if you've got
a monitor with this base mount you can
just get a mount that will rotate in
your own business but this old one
doesn't
but still just fyi
all right so we'll set that somewhere
now we've got a nice spot you can see my
super expensive monitor stands
there's thirty dollars there's a hundred
dollars there's
thirty or forty another 30 or 40. yeah
that's like a 300
stand right there
all right well we shouldn't need that
anymore while it's dusty back there
because now i have a stand that's gonna
give it the full lift
so i can reclaim my books
all right we're gonna keep this real
simple here
so it looks like this here stand
attaches
here and you just gotta screw
these through here lock it down
simple enough
and there we go
stand ready to go pretty quick set up so
far
all right so i guess we might as well go
ahead and get this
monitor set up on the vase amount as you
can see
it's ready to go we're just going to
lock it in and get it to click
so we're going to do that real quick
[Music]
and we're in business however we've got
to hook up all the cables so far
next so far whatever you want to say
everyone say it we've got to rotate this
there we go
there's the rotate you just you just
rotate it it's not it doesn't have a
button to press or anything
sweet all right i'm gonna log into my
computer this computer is actually on
right now
so go ahead and log in here
and now we're just using two monitors
but of course i want
all three of them going
all right so let's look at the
connections on this
and we'll see here i don't know if you
guys can see this is we got a vga
an hdmi and there's power and there's
audio
so maybe this has got little speakers on
it somewhere or a headphone jack or
something
i don't know i don't think it has
speakers but it does have an audio jack
or something i probably have a lot of
instructions for that however i'm not
concerned i'm not going to plug audio
into this
it's not in my interests
but this old cable that i was using for
the previous monitor it's not going to
work so we've got to do something
different
and i don't have any more hdmi ports
because this one's already hooked up to
hdmi
so i can't very well use that
however this monitor way over here
is what we're going to have to go with i
think
so i'm going to have to unplug this one
and it's using a special
ddi or let's see a display port to dvi
so we're gonna have to just change some
things up
get some of these things configured and
figure it out from there
so i'm kind of thinking maybe
let's see here
uh
oh no not this cable okay i've got a
cable that's like really
cheap and isn't
uh my favorite
because it's somewhat broken all right
so to be perfectly honest i should
probably turn my computer off to be
doing all this but
i'm pretty sure that i'm not gonna short
or anything or anything like that so i'm
not all that concerned
actually my bigger problem is these
cables aren't going to reach
very well because once i round it to the
back
so let's think about this a little bit
ah gonna have to do something
some improvising
[Music]
so i've got this new hdmi cable however
i don't have a slot for it down here
it's not sort of a problem
yeah why do video cards only have one
hdmi port i think
it's because how the audio works on them
they can only really have one audio out
and the hdmi carries the audio out
so i think that's what it is my webcam
off here
this and let's just take a look at this
old monitor
what kind of import options do i have
all right cool so we've got some that
could help a lot
oh my god
this might this is going to be the
messiest video ever but don't worry
we'll get it done right
all right ready you ready guys we're
going for ride
so this monitor
my god you has see hdmi
uh displayport that's it
hdmi displayport all right so
yeah i'm very happy being very careful
not to nudge the actual screen
face this is resting on its edge and on
its edge back here
the screen isn't bumping into anything i
know better than that
but now i have to decide how i'm going
to do all these cables and i think i'm
going to pause the video for a second
while i figure this out because
it's going to be a mess
all right so i got rid of the speakers i
moved some things and we're going to
figure this out i still want this over
here
and i think i'm going to have to use the
one hdmi on this one
ddi on this one or uh displayport on
this one
and then dvi on that one over there so
i've got i think i've got all these
cables i actually need to hunt and see
if i've got a proper dvi
or a displayport cable which i might not
have one so i have to order one of those
that's uh
that's a little bit disheartening i've
got to go dig through a box and see if
i've got a cable
that i need so i'll be right back
all right so fun times
fun times digging through boxes i came
up with some options
now i'm gonna have to you know just just
figure out what's best
but i've got this hdmi 2 dvi adapter
i've got this uh another
hdmi to display port adapter
i've got this vga to dvi adapter
yet another dvi cable that already has a
little vga
translation on the end
and just a plain vga that i hope i don't
have to use
i hope i don't have to go to vga because
that's non-digital
and uh sometimes you get some weird
lines in your screen from that they're
hard to notice but
you'll notice them if you compare and
contrast the difference so
let's let's figure it out i'm going to
pause the video again because this is
going to be
this is going to be a lot of figuring
out
okay i'll move my lighting a little bit
so first we're going to try this
db our uh
hdmi and see if this will do the trick
for the left monitor
that way it can keep the other two
monitors kind of the same and have to do
as little adjusting as possible i really
hope that this does the trick
we'll see
all right bringing a little closer here
all right so i got this left
vertical monitor all plugged in powered
up
and using that little cable i just
showed you so i'm gonna hit the power
button here
turns on that's a good sign and we're
basically going okay
it works so now we just need to make
sure we can get to go vertical
and to get it go vertical it's pretty
straightforward process you just
basically right click go to display
settings
and then click on the monitor you want
to configure
let's see it's
you know i need to get all the monitors
hooked up before i start doing this but
now that i know that that works i can
continue
because i need to get all three of these
arranged and then rotate the proper one
so i'm going to go ahead and do that
okay very good i just plugged in that
last one with that
dvi that was dangling the one that went
to the original one over here i switched
it over there so i think this thing's
gonna be confused and have them in the
wrong order
so we're just gonna go ahead and see if
we can get that all set up and nice and
that'll be the video
of getting it set up guys so let me know
if you have any questions
uh let's see here so
we're gonna click identify so it tells
us that the one on the left is three
this one's one that one's two
so three over there one in the middle
two on the right let's just check one
more time very good now we want to
rotate this one over here so i think we
can
we got it highlighted so we can operate
on it here and change it
to portrait
and it looks good keep changes so now we
can scroll over to the left side
and we should be able to go to the right
here looks like i've got to do some
adjusting of this because it considers
it
low but it's more actually like this
apply that
now i just need to find a cool
background that fits better so i should
be able to go over here
and then over here and then over here
and boom we are done
vertical monitor setup this should all
work pretty good from here
wasn't too bad just had to get all those
cables sorted out
and uh now it's back to
back to fun i guess all right thanks
guys for watching hope you enjoyed this
video and i'll see you in the next one